ellaria hilaria hillary whatever we're
calling her baldwin breaking her silence
on accusations that she faked her
spanish heritage for years
the wife of alec baldwin telling the new
york times that she never lied about her
background
and is being misrepresented by the media
she is also commenting on the now
notorious today show segment
where she did this we have very few
ingredients we have tomatoes
we have um a hottest cucumber cucumber
ellaria says she suffered from a quote
brain fart due to live tv
nerves um degen i know that i had never
used the cucumber emoji before and now i
have used it
three times since this story came out uh
what do you have to say about ellaria
this is me not making a joke about that
um
i i can eat up this story like boxes of
cinnamon toast crunch i just can't get
enough of it years ago
alec baldwin was on the letterman show
he was on the howard stern show
mimicking his wife's spanish accent so i
i think it sounds like he's in on it
but why didn't anybody in her family as
they would
have done in my family told her years
ago
what's with the accent what the hell are
you doing
what in the hell is the matter with you
what if i started going on tv
years ago and saying my name is dawkin
and i'm from the netherlands
my mom and dad would have both called me
on the phone and said you know what
we're pulling you off the air this is
absolutely ridiculous why isn't anybody
in her family like that
well now we all also know that dagin's
twang is definitely legit as her parents
would have pulled her off the air
um lawrence have you been getting into
this uh
this plot line i mean i've been watching
it i think it's funny
um i don't want her to be canceled but i
i do have a question for like
like liberals i don't what is up with
them wanting to be
other people other cultures like why
can't you just be
you i can't imagine myself trying to be
someone else like i love my coach i love
everything about it the food the co
the music everything about it and it
just seems like these people
just can't be them i think the person
that's most excited about this because
she won't be in headlines is elizabeth
warren
see i like this story i'm upset i've
been obsessed with this
i can't stop reading about it and i
wonder if she did it to try to land alec
baldwin which i'm not sure why anyone
would try to land alec baldwin because
he's not a catch
and he's clearly kind of crazy but you
know
she literally tried to fake try like
trying to pretend like she didn't know
the word cucumber and it's one thing to
like make one dish for a boyfriend
and pretend like you can cook when
that's really the only dish you know how
to cook
it's another thing to pretend like
you're something entirely that you're
not to try to pretend like you
are spanish just say you don't know how
to pronounce the word cucumber so i just
i find this to be so bizarre
and absolutely fascinating
jason is this bizarre and fascinating in
utah as well
oh we can't get enough of this story i
mean here you have alec baldwin of all
people
uh listen this is a person where she
said that her parents had a trouble
pronouncing the word baldwin
her mother who was born in the united
states is an assistant uh
professor of medicine at harvard her dad
it was is a georgetown trained attorney
she just making all this up and uh i i'm
pretty sure that uh
that's not the only thing she's faking
with alec baldwin but i'll leave it at
that